Oh  [Music]  okay so here we go last time I lost  against minus 14 let's try something a  bit easier let's play  well a little bit unusual but still  quite sound I would assume the point is  special p7 next what magnifier has other  more creative plans oh no we should be  someone and now the bishop back well  maybe there's some kind of deep plan but  I'm starting to get the suspicion that  he's just playing random moves now f6  that's kind of weakening the Kings side  meanwhile 95 just wanders the night so  it seems that now he's losing the thread  a bit now he actually found the only way  to blunder mate in one move which i  think is that not only shows a lack of  skill but it's also very very unlucky so  where's the mates I already clicked the  bishop so that's kind of a giveaway here  and the King has nowhere to go